brit hume is fox news's senior political
analyst he joins us tonight
hey brit great to see you i want there's
just i just
love the idea this contrast between the
way washington the press corps the state
department and kamala harris's office
thinks she's going to be received in
guatemala
and the way that she actually is i want
to play you a clip from a reporter
covering
kamala harris's we just got this her
trip to latin america
and this is slightly pornographic so i
want to apologize to our audience ahead
of time
here it is thank you madam vice
president for me it's an honor because i
actually got to vote for the first time
as a nationalized citizen and i voted
for you
so
so i just wonder if you're kamala harris
i don't want to be mean to camo harris
or anything but
like if you're surrounded by even the
reporters are sucking up to you it must
be a little surprising
when the guatemalan campesinos tell you
to go home
well tucker this kamala harris
phenomenon
is i think um limited to a small
subset of the american population of
which the news media are apart
and elements of the democratic party are
two
impression i have is from the polling
and so on and most americans don't
really get it
and i also have the sense tucker that
the reason kamala harris got this border
assignment was that
joe biden wanted to keep it as far away
from him as he could and
yet sound like he was doing something so
he names his
his newly uh in his newly sworn in vice
president to handle the matter
and then they quickly realized that oh
geez if we do and she goes to the border
that's only going to attract more
attention to this problem
so next thing you know or soon
thereafter
she heads down to to latin america
latin america to convene a root cause
seminar um
which when you think about it for a
minute is kind of a silly idea at this
stage of course it's a good idea to help
the people down there to deal with the
root causes
of whatever it is that makes those
people leave and come to the united
states
but this is that that's kind of a
long-term problem
the situation the border is a is a
current
uh immediate emergency requiring action
and and long-term solutions in central
america are even going to stop it
well i wonder i mean if you're kamala
harris it does i mean what do i know i
haven't talked to her about it but it
seems like this is
the last thing she wants to be doing
there's kind of no upside for her
how much do you think she resents being
dispatched to central america by the
by joe biden well i i couldn't
answer that question not being able to
get inside her head but the suspicion
grows
i think that what we have here is a
woman who
is a lightweight and she's useful for a
purpose like this you know you pack her
off to the border and you know you have
her do a few things here and there
and you know she had this this uh
statement today that she came out
and read after a meeting in mexico with
the authorities there
and the one thing was striking she
talked about root causes and all that
and all that
all sounds very good what there was no
mention of was any real concrete
current action that is being taken it is
all about
you know we we want to help these people
we want to you know they people don't
leave
their countries because they'd rather
stay they only leave because
circumstances
are dire so we want to help fix the
well that's fine but how long will that
take in the meantime
how many more immigrants will pour
across the border and the suspicion
grows i think tucker that the reason
that the body administration isn't
really doing anything down on the border
to
to enhance the enforcement down there is
they don't really want to
that there's a feeling within the party
that the more these people come
and the more they get into this country
the more they will they will eventually
become democratic voters
that's pretty cynical but i think that's
that's a big part of what's going on
we've had almost a million people show
up at the border so far almost a million
unbelievable britain i appreciate that
thank you very much for coming on
tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else